so this is a this is a topic that I've
intentionally tried to avoid since the
election and that's the reed litigation
of the primaries and more precisely the
argument between who what is the future
of the Democratic Party there's a future
of the Democratic Party live with Bernie
Sanders it doesn't live with someone
like Tom Perez now this is despite the
fact that Tom Perez and Bernie Sanders
are on a unity tour across the country
there seemed to be an unlimited supply
of pundits and commentators who want to
bring more division than actually exists
there seems to be a lot of unity pad
around Bernie Sanders the polling around
Bernie Sanders is but he's the most
popular active politician very popular
even amongst Hillary Clinton supporters
where matter of fact only three percent
of Hillary Clinton supporters view him
in a very unfavorable manner I think
that's really saying something too
because i think you know there are
plenty of people out there who disagree
with bernie sanders but they may still
be willing to approve of him because
they know that he's an honest guy and
has been the same on policy for the best
30 years yeah and very consistent very
very consistent which makes this article
from salon.com even more hilarious I
gave invited enter March who's the
author of this article on to to actually
discuss this but an in fairness to her I
just asked her maybe an hour before the
show so this is not a reflection on her
not being willing to discuss it more of
the fact that it should be discussed and
Anna if we get a chance we should talk
about this article but I'm going to talk
about it right now it's entitled bye bye
Bernie he's not fit to be captain of the
Democratic ship if he can't stop chasing
the great white male right so she sets
up a fairness to Anna this is the last
time going to give a caveat this is not
her original thought this is not her
original argument this is something that
has been pervasive and the Democratic
Party since the primaries it's a lie
that has been pushed all the way through
and it still exists but this is the
straw that broke the camel's back for me
I've been trying to avoid it but I just
can't take it anymore like I try to get
out but they pull me back in with this
ridiculous false premise and straw man
so the idea here is that Bernie Sanders
doesn't speak enough on behalf of race
issues in America
a number of other example great race
issues specifically and abortion this is
articles actually about abortion it's
actually positive and forwarding the
idea that bernie sanders is not a
progressive because he does not have a
good position on abortion and actually i
want to read a couple of he said she
said in the article i don't think we
have the quote for this one but i'll
read it she said we may have it yet
sanders has made it plain that abortion
rights are negotiable and brushes off
identity politics this is the most
flagrantly wrong accusation that I've
seen made in such a brash fashion Bernie
Sanders has a better position on
abortion rights than Hillary Clinton and
so the Ford this this distinct is to
just drop the sentence in the article
without any context without any
justification without any evidence is
obscene and then and then she goes on to
say that that he is also brushes off
identity politics I've never seen Bernie
Sanders brush off identity politics I've
seen Bernie Sanders do the exact same
thing that I do that you have to qualify
it identity identity politics are
imported but you cannot have it alone
this is the example that Bernie Sanders
has given a knife given a plenty of
times it's not enough to be a woman
running for office especially if you're
a woman running for office who is going
to do things detrimental to women taking
current case Catherine Pugh out of
Baltimore Baltimore ran for mayor she's
a black woman intersectional feminist
all these great things however she voted
against a 15 not voted let me be more
precise she be towed after the City
Council approved fifteen dollar an hour
minimum wage for the city of Baltimore
the black woman mayor of Baltimore
vetoed it now it's not enough you could
be a woman you could be black you could
be you know you could be LGBTQ you could
be all these things but identity is not
enough that's the justification and
that's the clarification that Bernie
Sanders makes it's the same distinction
that I may
and then to put this in an article to
continue getting clicks off of this
dribble where Bernie Sanders has a great
white male whole problem is nothing more
than a unnecessary read litigation and
it's divisive at best so here's some
other quotes from this that are just
completely ridiculous she said with
regard to Bernie Sanders that he
routinely divides matter of race and
gender and class which again cannot be
untwine by discussing the pain and needs
of working-class voters and perpetuating
the dangerous myth that Democrats have
ignored them Democrats have lost the
working class guess they got an
overwhelming amount of black working
class voters which she recites in this
article but you have to understand and
I'll talk for black I'll talk for black
working class people when we vote with
the Democratic Party because I very much
so working class for a long parts
portion of my life when we both with the
Democratic Party we're not voting for
the Democratic Party we're voting
against the Republican Party because the
Republican Party on top of being
detrimental to our economic livelihood
they are also bringing the added bonus
of racism right so many times
african-americans we vote against the
Republican Party more so than for the
Democratic Party but that's a
distinction will and we'll keep going
but this idea that Bernie Sanders
doesn't care about race let's play this
this is just one clip you can do a
random search on google and find Bernie
Sanders giving unequivocal support for
the african-american community on issues
of race let's watch this clue i dost be
very clear while we have overcome a lot
of racism we have come a long way we
still have a long way to go it is not
acceptable to be and I know to you that
an african-american baby a male baby
born today if we do not change things
sands a one in four chance of being in
prison during his life all right so
that's just one randomly googled clip of
Bernie Sanders own race if you actually
were sincere about this critique you
would see the Bernie Sanders has a very
long rich history of supporting issues
of race but this
the one that's the most disingenuous to
me Pat it's the fact that she has a
nerve to say that Bernie Sanders is uh
is a debt being pro-choice this is
actually her quote being pro-choice is
not an optional part of being
progressive full stop and then she
accuses him of making be a pro being
pro-choice as being optional here's a
problem and here's the context that
she's trying to set this in Bernie
Sanders has come out in support of Heath
mellow in Nebraska Heath mellow is a
Catholic he is personally pro-choice and
he essentially has the same exact
position on abortion as Tim Kaine Joe
Biden and a number of other Democratic
pro-choice Democrats to be redundant so
here is Bernie Sanders coming out in
support of heat mellow because he wants
to make sure that we keep a progressive
wave going but they have found that this
is an opportunity by day I mean the
Democratic establishment particularly
pundits who want to use this as a
divisive tool they have decided that
they're willing to scorch this race with
Heath mellow because this is an
opportunity for them to divide and
separate Bernie Sanders from being the
deep facto leader of the Democratic
Party here's the problem Bernie Sanders
has a better position on women's rights
reproductive rights and abortion then
even Hillary Clinton so what's the most
absurd part of this entire conversation
Pat is that Bernie Sanders in many ways
has a better position on unequivocal
support for women's rights and abortion
rights let's take a listen to Hillary
Clinton on abortion and Bernie Sanders
own abortion no yeah I've been on record
in favor of a late pregnancy regulation
that would have exceptions for the life
and health of the mother I object to the
recent effort in Congress to pass a law
saying after 20 weeks you know no such
exceptions because although these are
rare Brett they sometimes arise in the
most
complex difficult medical situation all
right so that's her position which is
not and I don't want anyone to mistake I
don't think her position is unreasonable
right but and she's made she's made an
exception she has she has a distinction
20 weeks there should be some regulation
here's Bernie Sanders though who is even
further to the left than me on this
issue who says that the government
should not be involved in it whatsoever
listen person of me being okay this look
thank you for the question but I happen
to believe and let me be very clear
better i know not everybody it will
agree with me i happen to believe that
it is wrong for the government ought to
be telling a woman what to do with her
own body and this is to the same exact
question to be clear Bret Baier asked
them do you support a exception for
late-term abortion Bernie Sanders no
Hillary Clinton with some exceptions and
again I don't just I don't necessarily
disagree with Hillary Clinton's position
but I disagree full-throated Lee full
hardly with this this incessant need by
political commentators to draw a
division to create and exacerbate a
division and the Democratic Party around
Bernie Sanders because they don't like
Bernie Sanders as being the titular head
of the Democratic Party I can't help it
if Bernie Sanders is as popular as he is
I can't help it if he's consistent on
his policies I can't help it if he has a
better position on abortion then Tim
Kaine the vice presidential candidate
underneath Hillary Clinton he does he is
the most popular Democratic president uh
active politician in the country right
now and there's no amount of articles
that you can write to undo that